in this video we're going to talk about
measuring public opinion and the first
question to ask yourself is why would we
even want to measure public opinion
well if we live in a democracy where a
public has a huge influence on our
government well you want to know what
they think and you can think about the
major institutions in our democracy you
could think about people who are in
office and they when they're making a
decision they would love to know what
the public actually thinks one they want
to act on behalf of the public and if
they want to get re-elected by the
public it might be in their interest to
know what the public thinks if you're in
the midst of an election and you want to
get elected well you might want to know
what does the public think about you you
might want to know what are your chances
of winning the election how are your
competitors doing or maybe what
positions should you highlight or maybe
which positions should you listen to the
public on similarly if you're an
interest group where is the public sit
on different things or how does their
opinion change over time
and a lot of what the media does is help
communicate
to the people what is going on broadly
in our society and that includes what
the people themselves are thinking
so now that we know that we want to
measure public opinion what are the
typical ways of doing so
you have the idea of a mass survey so
this is a way of just asking a lot of
people you want to randomly sample and
say
what do you think about some position
what do you think about some social
issue what do you think about some law
that is up for being passed what do you
think about some type of candidate now
the next three kinds of polls we have
listed here you could view as related in
a lot of ways to math surveys or even a
more specialized type of math surveys
you have the idea of a benchmark poll
and this is where at the beginning of
say a campaign you see how people feel
about a certain issue or a certain
candidate and then all future polls you
can compare to that benchmark
entrance and exit polls this is when
people actually go to vote when they're
about to enter into the voting booth you
ask them hey how are you going to vote
or right when they exit the voting booth
they ask you how or did you vote and
people aren't obliged to tell exactly
what they did but this will give an
indication of what is likely to be the
outcome of that election
related to both of these is the idea of
a tracking poll this is a situation
where you might ask people at the
beginning of some type of a campaign it
could be a campaign for candidate it
could be a campaign for a proposition
where this time you see okay what
percentage of people
are in favor of something so this would
be the percentage
in favor
and this is time
and then you periodically keep asking
the same group of people how they feel
about that candidate or that issue and
so you're going to be able to figure out
how people's opinions about that
candidate or issue change over time
you're going to be able to track that
and then a more i guess you could say
focused way of understanding public
opinion which might not be as
representative of the population as a
whole but allows you to get more maybe
more nuance than and more conversation
than these other four methods would be a
focus group this is where you try to
bring in a representative sample of 5 10
15 20 folks and have a discussion with
them about what what they care about and
why they care about these things
so i will leave you there in the next
video we'll talk about what makes for a
robust measure of public opinion